[موسيقى]
اذا الغيم تنهمر الحروف
فان لبست مقاليد المعاني مسطره تنوء بها
الرفوف
فتحنا في صميم العلم بابا فقال الدهر قد
جاز الوحوش
[موسيقى]
قال ابن جريج ما ظننت ان الله ينفع احدا
في شارع عمر بن ابي ربيعه حتى كنت ذات يوم
في اليمن عندما نحن زائده فسمعت رجلا ينشد
قوله بالله قولي له في غير ما اعتبره ماذا
اردت بطول المكث في اليمن ان كنت حاولت
دنيا او ظفرت بها فما اخذت بترك الحج من
ثمانيه قال فتركت اليمن وخرجت الى الحج
السلام عليكم
[موسيقى]
لفظ الحقيقه من اكثر الالفاظ الدائره على
السنه الناس اليوم عمتهم وخاصتهم لا يكاد
ياخذوا منه كتاب وكاتب ولا كلام متكلم فهم
يضعونها في موضع الحق والصدق واليقين
فيقولون قل الحقيقه بمعنى قل الصدق ولا
تكذب ويقولون ظهرت الحقيقه اي
ظهر الصدق
وصاروا ينسبون اليه فيقولون حقيقي وحقيقيه
يعنيون بذلك ان الامر حقا وصدق ويقين وليس
كذبا باطلا ومن ذلك قولهم هذا الشيء
حقيقيا دون انه صادق حقا كالمشاعر الصادقه
ونحوها ولعلهم يريدون بذلك تاكيد على
صدق الامر حقيقه الامر
حقيقه لم ترد القران الكريم ولكنها كثيره
في الشعر المحتج به فمن ذلك قول ابي
المسلم همم يرثي صخر الغي الهذلي بقوله
حامل حقيقه نسال الوديقه معتاق الوثيقه
جلد غير سنياني
قال الازهري والعرب تقول فلان يسوق
الوسيقه وينسل الوديقه ويحمي الحقيقه
فالوثيقه الطريده من الابل والوديق شده
الحر والحقيقه ما يحق عليه ان يحميه
عن ابن الاعرابي انه قال الحقيقه الرايه
والحقيقه الحرمه والحقيقه الفناء وروي عن
الليث انه قال حقيقه الرجل ما يلزمه
الدفاع عنه
خلاصه القول في معنى الحقيقه بلسان العرب
وفي اشعار العرب انها ما يحق على الرجل ان
يحميه ويدفع عنه من النساء والديار
والرايه وغيرها
وقولهم حامي الحقيقه هو اكثر ما تذكر فيه
الحقيقه من كلامهم وقليلا ما تذكروا في
غيره
[موسيقى]
كان ابن رهيبه شاعره في اواخر دوله بني
اميه وكان يشبب بزينب بنت عكرمه بن عبد
الرحمن بن الحارث بن هشام فافتضحك بذلك
فقام اخوها واستعد عليه هشام بن عبد الملك
فامره هشام بضربه 500 صوت وان يباح دمه ان
وجد قد عاد لذكرها وان يفعل ذلك بكل من
غنى شيئا من شعره فهرب هو والمغني الذي
كان يغني شعره واسمه يونس فلم يقدر عليه
ما هشام فلما ولي الوليد بن يزيد
ظهر وقال ابن رحيمه لان كنت اطردتني ظالما
لقد كشف الله ما ارهب ولو ليلت مني ما
تشتهي لقل اذا رضيت زينب وما شئت فصنعه
بعد ذلك فحبي لزينبا لا يذهب
سبحان الله بكل زمان دوله ورجال
اختباء في زمنه هشام وظهران في زمن الوليد
بن يزيد
[موسيقى]
قال النفري كلما اتسعت الرؤيه ضاقت
العباره ومن عرف الحجاب اشرف على الكشف
وقالوا اذا اردت ان يكون لك عز لا يفنى
فلا تستعجنا بعز يفنى
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
في استعاره الالوان يقولون عيش اخضر كنايه
عن الترف وموت احمر ونعمه بيضاء ويوم اسود
وايضا في استعارات الالوان يقول الشاعر
بيض وصنائعنا اسود وقائعون خضر مرابعنا
حمر مواضينا
وفي اوصاف الانف المحموده والمذمومه الشمم
هو ارتفاع قصبه الانف مع استواء اعلاها
طول الانف ودقه ارنبته وحدب في وسطه
والفطس
قصبه الانف مع ضخم ارنبته
والخنس تاخر الانف والذلف شخوص طرفه مع
صغر ارنبته
والخشب فقدانه حاسه الشم والخرم شق في
المنخرين والخفن عرض الانف ويقال ثور اخم
اما القعم فهو اعوجاج الانف
[موسيقى]
في ابيات تسديد رقه وعذوبه قال المجنون
متى يشتكي منك الفؤاد المعذب
وفهم المنايا من وصالك اقرب فبعد ووجد
واشتياق ورجفه فلا انت تدنيني ولا انا
اقرب كعصفوره في كف طفل يذمها تذوق رياض
الموت والطفل يلعب
بها ولا الطير درويش يطير فيذهب
قد عرفت طريقه ولكن الى قلبي الى اين اذهب
هذا لعمري شعر
يسكر العقول
[موسيقى]
كان هناك رجل اعرابي عليه
في يوم من الايام كان جالسا مع اصدقائه
فراى ابلا ترعى فقال مرتجلا ترعى العرار
الغضب
ثم
لم يعرف كيف يكمل هذا الشاطر
التفت فراى زوجته ام عمرو فما كان منه الا
ان قال
وام عمر طالق ثلاثه
فقال له طيب
فقال ذنبها انها قعدت على طريق القافيه
ترعى الاعرار الغضب
وام عمر طالق ثلاثه
بالمناسبه هي من الاعشاب التي تراها الابل
وترعاها الاغنام وهي كلمه صعبه في النطق
على من لا يعرف كيف يموضع فما هو عندما
يريد ان يلفظها قبل قليل عملت مسابقه
لفريق التصوير ههه كيف تقرا فيها هذه
بجد احسنت
احسن لاعب ما شاء الله يعني تفوق وجميعا
شو يا حسن
[موسيقى]
قل حاره فلان في امره وليس احتاره اذ لم
يعرف العرب فعل احتاره من قبل وفعل احتار
هذا خطا شائع وفي المعجم الوسيط حاره اي
تردد واضطرب وارتبك
للصواب تقول العرب حاره وتحير والسحار ولا
يقولون احتار
قل هذا حديث شائق ولا تقل شيئ الشائق في
اللغه الممتع الجذاب وما يشوق الانسان
بجماله وحسنه وما يحن بشوق اليه اما الشيق
فهو الشق بين صخرتين او في راس الجبل
قل اعددت فلان صديقا ولا تقول اعتبرت فلان
صديقا اللغه العربيه تستخدم الفعل اعتبر
بمعنى اتخذه عبره كما في الايه الكريمه
فاعتبروا يا اولي الابصار
[موسيقى]
كان احد الولايات يصلي خلف امام يطيل في
القراءه فنهاره الوالي امام الناس وقال له
لا تقرا في الركعه الواحده الا بايه واحده
فصلى بهم
وكان ماكرا فبعد ان قرا سوره الفاتحه قرا
قوله تعالى وقالوا ربنا انا اطعنا سادتنا
وكبرنا فاضلونا السبيلا
وبعد الفاتحه في الركعه الثانيه قراءه
قوله تعالى ربنا اتهم ضعفين من العذاب
والعنهم لعنا كبيرا فما كان من الوهل الا
ان اسرع ولا ده وقال يا امام طول ما شئت
واقرا ما شئت غيرها هاتين الايهتين
دمر المسكين
[موسيقى]
كنت قد سالتكم في تويتر كيف وصف العرب
الحرب في اشعارهم اشعار كثيره وصلتني منكم
في وصف الحرب استعرضوا معاكم بعضها
الشاعر زايد بن كروز يقول اذا ما فررنا
كان اسوا فرانا صدود الخدود وزورار
المناكب
هكذا هو البيت
والبيت لقيس بن الخطيب
من قصيده جميله يقول في بعضها في بعض
ابياتها تبدت لنا كالشمس تحت غمامه بدا
حاجبا منها وظنت بحاجبي
وقيس بن الخطيب قصائده كلها جميله
النائب ديما طهبوب ايضا شاركتنا في فقره
وسم ووردت ابيات جميله لقطر ابن الفجاءه
اقول لها وقد طارت شعاعا من الابطال ويحك
لن تراعي فانك لو سالت بقاء يوم على الاجر
الذي لك لن تطاع فصبرا في مجال الموت صبرا
فما نيل الخلود بمستطاعه سبيل الموت غايه
كل حي وداعيه وداعيه لاهل الارض داعيه
مكتوب سبيل الموت لغايه كل حر وانا اتوقع
انها غايه كل حي والله اعلم
اماني العربي تقول يا نصف امنيه ونصف
روايه
حلما توارثه الدخان وضاع يا كل مقتول بغير
جريره لم يمنحه للمتعبين وداع اني لاخجل
من عروبتنا التي تركت حمانا للعدادات
مشاعر الله
جميل ومؤلم
حبيبه وردت ابيات تعرفونها كلكم طبعا متى
ننقل الى قوم رحانا يكون في اللقاء لها
طحينه يكون تفالها شرقيا نجد ولهوتها قضاه
اجمعين
عمرو بن كلثوم
ومن لا يعرف عمرا محمد اورد ابيات اللي
عنتره انا في الحرب العواني غير مجهول
المكان اينما نادى المنادي في لجنه ايراني
وحسام مع قناتي لفعالي شاهداني انني اطعن
خصمي وهو يقضان الجناني
وهذا من
الامور التي فيها الكثير من النبل والكرم
ان لا تطعن خصمك غدرا وتطعنه في ظهره
عنتره يقول انني اطعن خصمي وهو يقضان
الجنان لا اخذه غدرا على حين غره
حمد يقول يعجبني بيت عنتره حينما يصف فرسه
قائلا خاض العجاج محجلا حتى اذا شهد
الوقيعه عاد غير محجل
جميل
جميل جدا
مشاركاتكم حقيقه غايه في الجمال
والروعه
واختم بهذه المشاركه من نوال وما الحرب
الا ما علمتم وذقتموا وما هو عنها بالحديث
المرجم متى تبعثوها تبعثوا هذا ميمه وتظرا
اذا ضريتموها فترضني والابيات طبعا لزهير
بن ابي سلمى
اشكر لكم هذا التفاعل الجميل
ونسال الله دائما ان يجيرنا ويجيركم من
ويلات الحروب
واذكركم بان تضعوا بس انت تاملات الجزيره
دائما عند نهايه كل المشاركه
لن اقول انها شاعره او اديبه ولا نقول
انها كانت دبلوماسيه
ساقول كانت نخله من نخلات العراق العظيم
واحده من ابرز اصوات جديده لميعه عباس
عماره شاعره عراقيه لاعب الدور الرئيسيه
في تطوير حركه الشعر
في الوطن العربي في عصر ان لمعت فيه اسماء
كبيره
[موسيقى]
عباس عماره في العام
1929 في بغداد قادمه من مدينه العماره
الجنوبيه او المعروفه بتاريخها العريق لم
تنتظر كثيرا حتى نشرت قصيدتها وهي لما
تتجاوز الخامسه عشره من العمر كان ذلك في
عام 44 وفي مجله تدعى السمير وبمساعده من
الشاعر اللبنانيه المعروف ايليا ابو ماضي
الذي كان صديقه عمها هذا الشاعر تنبا لها
بمستقبل شهري باهر
قائلا اذا كان في العراق مثلها هؤلاء
الاطفال فعلى اي نهضه شعريه يقبل العراق
درست في دار المعلمين العاليه وتزاملت
هناك مع شخصيات ستصبح شهيره لاحقا امثال
بدر شاكر السياب ونازك الملائكه وعبد
الوهاب البياتي
وابن خالتها عبد الرزاق عبد الواحد
مع هؤلاء وناسك الملائكه
لاحقا ستشكل الشاعره جبهه
متحده لتطوير الشعر العربي وتخليق قصيده
التفعيله اذا جاز التعبير
تخرجت في عام 55 حامله الاجازه في اللغه
العربيه
وبرز صوتها الشريك صوت مختلف
وكطاقه لا تهدا اذا تميز شعرها بجراته
ولغته القويه فقالت
لو انبا ان العراف
لو انبا ان العراف انك يوما ستكون حبيبي
لم اكتب غزلا في رجل
خرساء اصلي لتظل حبيبي لو انبا ان العراف
اني سالامس وجه القمر العالي لم العب بحصل
غدران ولم اظن من خرز امالي لو انبا ان
العراف ان حبيبي سيكون اميرا فوق حصان من
ياقوت شدتني الدنيا بجدائلها الشكر فلم
احلم اني ساموت
لو انبا ان العراف ان حبيبي في الليل
الثلجي سياتيني بيده الشمس لم تجمد رئه
ولم تكبر في عيني هموم الامن
كتبت في قضايا المراه وكانت صوتها القوي
في تلك المرحله فهي وبحسب الكاتب العراقي
عقيل عباس عملت انقلاب هائلا في الشعر
لانها ركزت على مفهوم الحريه وكانت صوتا
للمراه مضيفا انها كانت جريئه جدا في
تناول المراه كذلك لانها تتحدث عن الرغبه
والمشاعر وذلك في مجتمع ذكورا حتى في
الشعر
بالاضافه الى ذلك ابتسم شعرها بشيء من قوه
الشتيمه والشخصيه فقالت في قصيدتها
المعروفه
انا عراقيه والتي ارتجلتها عندما حاول احد
الشعراء مغازلتها في مهرجان المربد
الشريفي ثمانينيات القرن الماضي في العراق
طبعا
اتدخنين لا تشربين لا ترقصين لا ما انت
جمع من الله فقالت انا عراقيه
لم تكتفي جميع عباس بالعمل الثقافي
بالعاميه في السلك الدبلوماسيه شغلت منصب
الممثل الدائم للعراق في منظمه اليونسكو
في باريس بين عامين 735
واصدرت مجموعه من الدواوين الشهريه نذكر
منها الزاويه الخاليه وعوده الربيع واغاني
عشتار
ويسمونه الحب ولو انبانى العراف والبعد
الاخير
اعجب بها الشاعر العراقي الراحل بدر شاكر
السياب وانشد فيها
ذكرتك يا لميعه والدجاجه وامطار
ولندن مات فيها الليل ما تتنفس النور
رايت شبيهه لك شعرها ظلم وانهار
من الحور
مريضا كنتم تثقل كاهلي والظهر
كانت لميعه شابه بارعه الجمال وزامله
الصيام في دار المعلمين العليا هذا ما
جعله يفتن بها ويترك قصائد عديده تتحدث
عنها حتى ان كثيرين يقولون ان قصيده المطر
يسمونها انشوده المطر
عن تلك العلاقه التي جمعتهما
سالت يعني في لقاء مع الروائي العراقي
انعام كشاكيل فقالت من الاكيد انني كنت
احبه وقد كتبت له شعرا وتاثرت كثيرا
بصداقتنا التي لم تكن اكثر من علاقه بريئه
ومحلقه ومبدعه
وهي كانت فتره غنيه جدا في حياه بدر
تقول توقفت تقريبا فيها عن كتابه الشاعر
طويله الفتره التي عرفته فيها وكنت مكتفيه
بدور ملهم والمستمع والناقد والرفيق
والصديق كنت الامه والحبيبه فكان انتاج
قليلا وانتاجه غزيرا وكنت سعيده بصداقته
وراضيه
انتهى قولها
في نفس الوقت لم تكتفي لميعه عباس بان
يكتب هو عنها فكتبت هي ايضا عنه وتركت له
قصائده حاكيه فيها كقصيده شهرزاد والتي
كتبتها في مرحله دراستهما معا
ستبقى ستبقى شفاء
ويبقى بعيني هذا النداء ولم يبرح الصدره
هذا الحنين ولن يخرس اليئس كل الرجاء
ترحلت الشاعره لميعه عباس في سبعينيات
القرن الماضي من العراق الى الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه
وتحديدا الى سانتياغو على الساحل الغربي
وعاشت بقيه حياتها هناك حتى وافتها المنيه
في عام
2021 عن عمر يناهزوا 92 عاما
رحلت لمياء عباس وبقيت اشعارها وبقيه
روحها
تتغلغل في ثنايا هذه القصائد التي مازلت
الى هذا اليوم كلما قراته شيئا منها اقول
اني لا اجد رائحه العراق
[موسيقى]
احد الاصدقاء يطلب مني النظر في بعض
الامور من اجل ابداء الراي والملاحظات هذا
الامر سهل جدا بالنسبه لي ولا يشق عليه
ابدا لكن هو من كرامه يراه امرا كبيرا جدا
ويرى انه يكبدني عداء ومشقه
فحدث قبل ايام انه كلمني فقال هناك امرا
اريدك ان تنظر فيه فهل تريده باجر ام
بموده قلت بل اريده بموده خالصه
فلما انجزت الامر قال لي اشكرك
فكتبت اليه قائلا
وحسبي منك تكليفي بامر وتقديمي له دون
العباد مراد ليس حمدا او شكورا لعمري ان
خدمتكم مرادي السلام عليكم
[موسيقى]